today we're going to be discussing the
three pillars of success with a very
special guest someone that I've worked
with before at a couple of our events
he's really changed the game in so many
of different industries I won't try and
introduce you yourself
but Gary welcome to the show thanks for
having me extended me here
so Gary you've got a really interesting
background I think obviously moving into
the u.s. the baseball cards the Wine
Library perhaps or some of the people
around familiar with yourself can you
intro you know it's fun right now I'm
very much known as a marketing guy a
social media guy but the truth is at the
end of day it's why I really wanted to
do this today is I'm a sales guy right I
mean from the age of five with lemonade
and I mean five lemonade stand franchise
really doing sales to the core of my
adolescence which was be a poor student
but sell pencils and erasers and bubble
gum and and ultimately because I'm a 41
year old male and baseball cards were a
huge phenomenon in America
I was selling baseball cards at 12 13 14
15 and making thousands of dollars a
weekend selling baseball cards but it
was sales sales and then my dad saved
all his money as a Russian immigrant you
mentioned I wasn't born in the US and
bought a small liquor store in
Springfield New Jersey and my late teens
early 20s were about hand selling wine
you know you come in for Santa Margarita
Pinot Grigio and I'm going to try to
sell you the Pinot Grigio we make more
money on that we think is better so that
has been the constant
I actually think branding and marketing
is sales it's just top of the funnel
work we were just talking about that
before camera the book that the new TV
show I'm doing it's all sales at the end
of the day and so I'm an entrepreneur
for everybody's watching built a very
large e-commerce wine business in the
late 90s early 2000s called
winelibrary.com
and then saw the world changing was
using email marketing Google AdWords
banner retargeting and then ultimately
YouTube as sales and marketing funnels
for my wine store YouTube sells for two
billion dollars 1.7 to Google I think
this is a big change in the world the
internet I decide that my skill of
understanding consumers can make me more
money in my quest to buy the New York
Jets which is
my Auckland business ambition and I
decide to become an investor like
Forestry investments for Facebook
Twitter and Tumblr I did very well and
and then I decided seven years ago to
take a step back and build a sales and
marketing machine and that became
vaynermedia which I started with my
brother AJ seven and a half years ago
almost eight years ago and over the last
six years we've grown from 30 to 700
employees to to a hundred thirty million
dollar agency full-service media buying
creative production planning all that
work and and in January this year I
created a holding company called Vayner
X with my acquisition of pure well a
female mid modern media company and so
now we have a publishing arm and and the
agency and at the end of the day all of
it one way or the other gets into the
sales world right and so clearly the
investments you've made in those
different companies what you're doing
with vaynermedia disrupting the whole
media industry in general the whole
sales world and buying world has been
completely disrupted number one from a
technology point of view there's clearly
so many technologies out there but then
also number two around the actual
mindset of that via another salesperson
people don't want to be sold - I've
always found it really interesting you
create all this content you put it out
there for free and a lot of people kind
of question that ago why would you do
that for free but I'm a strong believer
you need to give these insights out for
free and ultimately build that
connection so for any sales
professionals watching where would you
advise that they start in terms of
creating their own content or sharing
their content adding their own context
as well before I go directly into the
tactics of should you make a video
should you do a written blog post or she
do do a podcast I think the bigger thing
is and I think you get this as well is
you have to reverse engineer who you're
trying to get to you know if your
salesperson out there right now if
you're trying to get to me and so many
of you are I get 50 70 bulk emails both
direct messages bulk Twitter direct
messages Instagram business cards all
sorts of weird stuff
sent in the mail I'm busy right I'm busy
and like I'm just not interested in you
selling to me not because I don't like
you because I respect the game it's
because I'm just busy nothing personal
so I think the first thing you have to
do is reverse engineer the person you
know because I'm not in the market to
buy anything I'm going to be tougher but
if I need certain software if I need
something that's a good time to attack
right so I think the number one rule of
salespeople is to listen know your
audience know what they did if you see
an M&A just happen if you see layoffs
just happening if you see one of them if
I see Burger King doing something I'm
thinking what does mcdonald's think of
right that's number one number two where
they spending time i'm easy to sell to
if you realize that i'm spending time on
social networks but i'm not going to
want you to spam me in my direct message
with a linked and no context you should
be producing content for me to see it in
my feed I think to answer a question
directly everybody as a sales person has
to figure out how do they best
communicate is it written word is it
audio is it video is it in person and
how to use the digital world in audio
written or video form to create the
gateway drug to in-person one thing that
people are very confused by me is I
don't even do phone call sales calls I
need to see you face-to-face I'm
supposed to be this digital guy and I
need to see you I use digital and I use
all my content on YouTube Facebook
Instagram snapchat LinkedIn medium as
gateway drugs to this so I think anybody
who's a salesperson whether on you're an
entrepreneur startup and you're not
producing content at scale podcast video
blog blog posts random twitter facebook
Instagram YouTube clips then you're
losing that is unacceptable in 2016 that
is losing DNA if you're not producing
content for social networks and the
mobile device and the platforms on it
you basically don't exist sometimes a
lot of people may try a new initiative
and then they don't get an immediate
reaction and they think it's a failure
okay I want to get your YouTube videos
with the Wine Library you know you had
so much content out there how did you
stick in there how did you keep yourself
motivated because I believe in my
oh geez and I'm patient as [ __ ] like all
great stuff especially when you're
innovating doesn't happen right away
this notion of like Oh Gary I tried it I
spent 500 bucks on Facebook ads it
doesn't work well what's your video suck
what if your product and service sucks I
I tend to do things that are very early
that has been my career I when I do
things I believe in them I stick with
them based on intuition even though for
18 months nobody watched my wine videos
at all I knew it was right I was right
there's been things I've done that I
jumped off of very quickly I started to
Gary B app-v chat ve like we Chad's I
was funny for my fans great CRM one on
one didn't feel right after a week or
two spent plenty money building it knew
it stopped it after you know a couple
months of Wine Library TV five years
every day YouTube decided to change it
to daily grape insular app you could buy
stuff subscription for reviews it was a
lot of fun only did it for five months
stopped it because they didn't feel
right anymore it's always hard to know
when to jump off something new but I
find that people don't believe in what
they're doing they hear a guru and they
do it begrudgingly because their boss
wants them to or they're like well
Gary's right a lot so let me do it but
they don't believe it and so then they
jump they're looking for nose instead of
yes is everything I do every business
development every event I do every time
I try new marketing tactics or sales
tactic I'm looking for the yes right I'm
looking for the yes and if the no
punches me well then I'm like crap then
no punched me I believe the majority of
people when they try new tactics are
looking for the no and you're going to
getting a lot of subtle knows
immediately right and so I think that's
why that happens you mentioned to a guru
that I know you met up with Tony Robbins
the other day and he also did that great
Netflix documentary I am NOT your guru
yes I'm the fact that he cursed and say
Ruffini grateful for that it was it was
really interesting just hearing the
dialogue between the two of you because
again to your point people look at these
gurus or foot leaders and then maybe try
something and then just go it doesn't
work and I'm playing you for it yeah I
mean honestly like I don't even I the
good news for me is I'm not selling my
audience anything so I have very
very good vibes with my community
because we're not selling them anything
it's really easy you don't get really
blamed they may have a judgment call on
your stuff doesn't work and that's fine
I think that a lot of people that are
watching this right now don't have the
talent to achieve what they want to
achieve human people I've met that
wanted to be great salespeople like an
you know if you're a salesperson you can
smell other salespeople you know it's
like dogs sniffing each other it's not
super confusing to me and I'm like
you're not going to be a Salesman or
[ __ ] you're gonna be a great salesman at
these so I yeah I mean being a thought
leader or having a personal brand or
doing the self promotion or this and
that it's part of my world but it's
really something I spent very little
time thinking about I'm an operator the
Gary B thing is my side hustle I'm
running a very large organization and
company and I'm very empathetic and I
try to be very frank with my audience I
have a piece of content that's really on
the verge of huge virality where I spoke
to a 22 year old home I asked a TV show
the other day for like 20 minutes really
dug in with her she was really great and
it was very real and the reality is is
that a stunning amount of people behind
that camera right now are not going to
be successful in sales because they're
not willing to work hard enough they
love the automation they love your
product right you guys do great like
they love all these tools the problem is
if you have the greatest hammer and the
greatest screwdriver and the greatest
wrench the brightest in front of you if
you don't use them properly you will
lose right if there's a nail that I have
to put in that ground but I take the
wrench and I hit it when the hammer was
right there it still comes down to the
practitioner mm-hmm and you have to be
good at your craft and you have to love
you if you love sales if you don't love
it you have no chance because it's so
hard it's so painful there's so much
objection right so those are the things
I think about so technologically
enablers you just said that the person
is equally important and more important
right and go back for you thank you I
just apologize for jumping in but let me
make it perfectly straight if I go play
Roger Federer right now in tennis and
I'm the greatest
racket ever made like from taken from
the Mars as new like resources right and
he took a John McEnroe 1974 tennis
racket he would whip my ass like I'm
crushing sales people that have every
sales force every one of your
competitors 37 features upgraded went to
every pro conference watching this I
will beat their ass in sales every day
of the week right your talent right -
Gary that we did up on time we loved any
closing thoughts from you for sales
professionals whether it's startup at an
enterprise what should they go out and
do today tomorrow I look at sales very
differently than the far majority I
think way too many salespeople are
patient are impatient I think way too
many salespeople are transactional I
think way too many salespeople are
lowest common denominator
spam blast LinkedIn email bulk business
card business card business cards so I
think I've got a different tactic on
sales but don't get it twisted it's what
I am if you're not happy with your
upside if you're not fully fulfilled I
think a lot of what you heard for me
today I'm doing things reverse of you I
think a lot of you are doing things that
are directly in front of you numbers
that they put in front of you you're
trying to achieve that because you have
a beach house you want to buy we're
going that vacation sales is a funny
game if you work in a big company they
manipulate numbers to create your
actions I believe that the best
salespeople are doing things in a
different way I think you need to care
about the customer for real
reverse-engineer them and give them what
they need and so I have a funny feeling
that for 87.9% arbitrary number that
eighty seven point nine percent of the
people watching right now I'm a better
salesperson than you because I'm the
anti salesperson and I think that's the
best salesperson think about that think
about how you give yourself air cover to
not do behavior that a short term please
understand that the world has changed in
the attention of the person you're
trying to get to is moving in to
different places and and and this big
one
stop complaining sales people aren't
allowed to complain the market is the
market your bosses are your bosses a
great salesperson
shuts their mouths and she goes to work
everyday and tries to bring value to the
end-user and his pension and overtime
wins the marathon of sales put yourself
in that position
[Music]